what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
okay so we are covering x-men black
Magneto the one shot and these are like
a Preet like a series of one shots that
lead to like the relaunch of uncanny
x-men right these are really designed
more for the purpose of really one kind
of going back to like the old school
standard for x-men storytelling and to
kind of preparing people for what to
expect with uncanny x-men and so because
of the nature of that it actually makes
sense that Chris Claremont is writing
the one shot for magneto because again
you know Chris Claremont's well-known as
being like the x-men writer I mean he
wrote the damn comics for 17 years but
one thing to bear in mind when it comes
to Chris Claremont and his whole x-men
run was that you had a really
interesting situation in terms of how
his stories would be told right like he
focus a lot on character development
so now usually what you get with stories
is this like a Vin after event after
event after event and that's really
about it the Chris Claremont era of
storytelling is really reminiscent of a
bygone age and so it's really just like
like action-packed events non-stop so
take for example like when he first took
up the x-men right you wrote like the
Phoenix saga well you you know that runs
with 97 or 98 all the way up to 107 like
a hundred and seven or so along those
lines and then you get like twenty or
thirty issues and then you go into Dark
Phoenix and then you get like another I
don't know like like five or six issues
and then you get Days of Future past so
as one of those things where like you
would have a vin after event but it
would be interspersed or really it
really separated and kind of sandwiched
between a huge amount of storytelling
when it came to the characters and it
was a way for Chris Claremont to shift
the x-men away from being just a team
that fought things to being like a
dynamic team where everybody had their
own individual distinct personalities a
soap opera if you will and so what this
does is it initially picks up with
Magneto now in reality that comics a
little preachy but with regards to like
Magneto's character it is cool because
it gives you kind of a throwback to
something akin to the white Chris
Claremont wrote but this initially
picked up with magneto inside the Gold
Star Cafe and this is just kind of a
cafe that he happened to spot as he was
walking along and he's met by a young
girl named Kate now this is a cool
discussion they have because as the two
of them are talking they begin to sort
of talk about the nature of like the
diner that they're in and Kate talks
about her mom about how her mom went off
she was basically deployed and it's kind
of a cool thing because what Kate ends
up noticing is the numerical brand
that's on Magneto's arm and it's kind of
crazy because he tries to shy away he
tries to move away from it all but one
of the things that's also interesting
here is like the old versus the new and
it's almost kind of like a stand-in for
the way comics are right I mean we
talked about that at the beginning you
know you
at old school standard of storytelling
where it was very very long and very
very drawn-out in reality if Chris
Claremont started riding the uncanny
x-men now the way he wrote them back
then a lot of people would probably get
bored people are moving it like a mile a
minute now and they want their stories
like super fast pace but with with this
discussion kind of isolated as it is man
you know talked about how he reads books
right he just likes reading physical
books whereas this girl Kate she likes
reading things on digital and it's kind
of like well times have changed old man
it's not the way that he used to be
things are totally different now but
from here we end up having Kate again
recognized this brand this numerical
brand on Magneto's arm and this is when
he says he got it when he was in
Auschwitz now the other half here is
that Kate really talks about this diner
as being intrinsically tied into the
nature of her family's history now given
the complexion of Kate we could kind of
go either way that she's probably a
possibly african-american but given the
way your hair is drawn it looks like
she's Jewish and that the store itself
near the cafe itself being called the
gold star is reminiscent of the role of
Jews or at least a position they were
put in by Germans and concentration
camps and what I mean by that is in in
truth during World War two the Jews were
required to wear a yellow stars they
weren't really gold but it is the idea
that like it's predicated on remembering
their history remembering their past and
so there's a pretty important thing and
it really seemed to be one of the
reasons why magneto hit on it so it's
really it really seems to be tied to the
Jewish history in a sense that is called
the Gold Star Cafe that rings a bell
with magneto himself and it doesn't a
couple different ways Marvel has over
the years if you go back and read like
classic x-men you know 110 111 114 you
do get some history of magneto there but
I would say the most comprehensive
origin story for magneto himself came
during the Testament story that are I
guess really the Testament miniseries
that was done by Greg Pak and that
focused very heavily on magneto in his
youth when he was in Auschwitz and it
built on all that stuff that came after
in terms of him going on to form of life
by himself you know meeting Magda and so
on and so forth or two of them getting
married and so on and so that's why
things like this little tidbits like
this are really cool because if you
followed x-men as long as I have you see
these small little tidbits these small
little things that are thrown in that
really kind of remind you of a ajita for
example how he relates to Kate is very
reminiscent of when he took over the
x-men and he was leader of the New
Mutants and so it's awesome to sort of
see those small little things kind of
coming home to roost you know and seeing
Chris Claremont finally coming home to a
title that he worked so hard on and made
so spectacular because in reality
everything you know and love about the X
is all due to chris claremont that's it
it really is it really all rests on his
shoulders but from here we end up
getting this televised news broadcast
that picks up on the office of national
emergency Oh in II and the idea that
they've basically begun the gun the
process of creating like camps around
the entire country where mutants are
going to be stationed now that's always
been an on running theme when it comes
to the mutant population of Marvel
Comics it's one of the reasons why
mutants were always a great allegory for
like any particular oppressed group for
the fact that they are mutants because
of the fact that they're the next stage
in human evolution it means that they're
constantly forced into internment or
they're constantly put down upon they're
constantly segregated or something along
those lines but with the office of
national emergency is doing it's really
moving in the direction of the most
feared process for mutants which is to
say the coming of Days of Future past
that eventually something will happen a
tipping point will take place and
mutants will be subjugated by humanity
and it's very it really kind of strikes
a chord because for magneto he's lived
through this
he lived in a society where these people
here are undesirable therefore we need
to enter them we need to throw them in
jail and we need to keep them away from
everybody else Magneto's lived through
that for Kate she has it for this young
girl she's never lived through any of
that stuff and Magneto kind of feeds on
that a bit and kind of says yeah it is
it's absolutely terrifying because what
happens when they start going for
everybody when it stops being mutants
and them starts being people based on
skin color now of course this leads
directly into a handful of people at the
bar basically stepping up and you know
kind of doing their doing their thing
you know you're different from us we
don't like you you know and magneto kind
of lets it go now this is one of the
things that Claremont's really kind of
hitting out here magneto over the years
has changed and that's really what
Claremont's doing in this particular
part of the story because if this was
magneto from like 1977 or for like 1983
he would have just killed him this is
one of those things where just kind of
comes with wisdom
if magneto lashed out and killed these
guys he would have tracked unwanted
attention and possibly even rain down
havoc on the on the Goldstar cafe and
bring them a whole bunch of undue
hardship and if they're mutants you know
if anybody in the the ghosts are cafe or
mutants didn't whisk them away but for
Cait herself she's actually not because
where she steps in and she tells
everybody you guys have to calm down you
guys have to stop she shows them the
brand on Magneto's arms think this guy
was a was in a concentration camp this
guy knows what the situation is like you
know you guys are just kind of sitting
on your high horses and you're you know
you're ranting and raving about the
return of something that you don't know
anything about but they don't really
know what they're asking for what
they're asking for it comes from
knowledge of like documentaries and
textbooks they didn't live through it
that's one of the funny things about
humanity
in the in the comics is when you look at
humanity versus mutants is one of those
things where humanity's like yeah
everything is fine so long as it's only
the mutants who were being dealt with
and so it's kind of a funny scenario
when you see these diametrically opposed
engrossed art of facing off against each
other and so what this does is it leads
into magneto going through kind of a
training process here and this is cool
because where he's on asteroid M this
training process he indoors is a way for
him to basically hone his skills he's
using his abilities to face off against
the x-men consistently in terms of these
simulated simulated events he's similar
to training sessions and does it with
the safety protocols off meaning it's
entirely possible he may get himself
killed doing this but for Magneto it's
worth it because we've seen how how
strong he can be against the x-men and
how formidable of an enemy he can be but
what he ends up doing is basically
launching an attack on one of the
facilities traveling directly to you
know San Fernando and Texas intending to
liberate people now this is this is a
throwback to the old way of Magneto way
back in the early days when he was more
extreme he would have just shown up here
and just wipe everything out and it'd
just been like like everybody's dead you
know issue an EMP and all the soldiers
are dead normally in all kind of stuff
take him out do whatever he needs to do
and then save the mutants instead he's a
lot more reserved now and so he shows up
here and basically says they would
expect like a vehicle to flying a come
flying up here not some man who could be
a reporter or any number of things and
so he begins to face off against one of
these sentinels the sentinels themselves
are designed for the purpose of facing
off against Magneto given the fact that
he has magnetic powers but what they
assume is that Magneto's gotten weaker
over the years did I need those nowhere
near as powerful as he used to be and
what he basically says is that's not
true
you know he's essentially just kind of
like tricking them into believing he's a
lot weaker than he is so they'll
essentially let their guard down because
what would happen here is you would have
this signal this this man Sentinel it
would show up to fight Magneto the
signal would obviously get the upper
hand and then everybody inside the base
would just kind of be like the signal
will take care of him just let
everything else go and in that moment
magneto would basically take out the
Sentinel and strike and that's exactly
what he does he ends up dismantling this
signal in its entirety like the metal
the physical form the whole nine yards
breaks it apart in pieces and then in
turn is exposed to this woman who looks
like she's Kate's mom or at least
somebody somebody similar to that and
this girl's like I'm 100% right that
you're the wrong kind of people and
that's where the whole argument comes
down to is that mutants are good and
your mutants are people they're just not
the right kind of people and because of
not the right kind of people we have to
contain them and we have to control them
that's the nature of humans were
as mutants and marvel comics and so in
this moment magneto kind of realizes
there may be no saving this girl like
she may very well be beyond any real
measure of redemption but he ends up
letting her live anyway which is a
little strange what he does is literally
take out the entire electronic system in
the building issues an EMP basically
tells her look you know I'm liberating
all these mutants here if you come after
me I will kill you and it was really
kind of a warning and so this kind of go
is really a lot until I filled sanctuary
stories from the x-men comics where
Magneto you know flew around and
liberated all these mutant camps and
then took the mutants into space and
just kind of live there and so on it's a
pretty cool pretty cool bit of
storytelling and so grabbing these
mutants and then liberating them and
then basically walking away it means
that it gives him the chance to regroup
to kind of reform his army but what are
the things that he says here this is why
it's so important one of the things that
he says here is that he's barely begun
to tap into his power that he's barely
begun to tap into his true potential and
what he's truly capable of no this is
chris claremont writing this and this is
technically a one-shot what this
indicates is that one magneto is a lot
more powerful that he's letting than
he's letting on to magneto himself
doesn't really even know the upper
limits of his powers and three his upper
limits may be something just
outrageously powerful because when
you're talking about controlling
magnetism and controlling metal and so
on and so forth you're talking about
controlling the molecular structure of
things you only like the electron bonds
between objects and so when you're
talking about controlling that you're
controlling the fundamental forces of
the universe now whether or not this
would go in the direction of magneto
becoming god I don't really know at the
end of the day reality manipulation is
reality manipulation is reality
manipulation and it doesn't really
matter how you do it it's a matter of
how it's written and so you know if
magneto reached that point where he
could control like the atomic structure
of matter by using magnetism itself he'd
be no different than somebody like
Franklin Richards it's just the means by
which he does it so it is kind of cool
to see how this whole thing unfolds and
how this whole thing happens there is
also degeneration with deals with which
which deals with apocalypse we're gonna
cover that later because this is
actually a five-part backup feature
which actually looks really really cool
but without being said guys we're gonna
bring this video to an end if you are
new here to comments explained make sure
you guys at the sub button to become
part of the rob4 if you guys enjoy this
video make sure you drop a like and I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]